Oui
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous
merci de répondre toujours aussi nombreux à l'invitation de l'Espace des sciences
et on est très heureux de vous accueillir ce soir encore pour un nouvel épisode
du mardi de l'Espace des sciences une conférence
qui comme chaque conférence chaque semaine a été organisée programmée par Maëtte Chantrel
sauf que ce soir elle m'a confié les clés de la maison
elle a pris quelques jours de repos bien mérité mais vous la retrouverez dès la semaine prochaine
un mot pour vous dire que comme très souvent
désormais chacune de nos conférences sont filmés vous pourrez donc la revoir à partir de demain sur la chaîne
YouTube de l'Espace des sciences que vous connaissez peut-être
certainement
y accéder aussi à travers via le site de l'Espace des sciences ou bien encore de la revoir sur la chaîne TVR
ce soir nous sommes ravis de recevoir un jeune chercheur
breton qui plus est soyons fiers alors ce lot soulignons le
venezuela applaudissent et le
Vous allez voir qu'il a plus une raison en plus d'être applaudi
julien gigot qui est notre invité ce soir alors il est né tout au fond de la bretagne après c'est l'amérique à brest
voilà mais l'amérique vous êtes passés aussi d'ailleurs
on va en parler un petit peu un petit peu ensemble vous êtes aujourd'hui
rennais d'adoption vous êtes installé depuis quelques mois ça fera bientôt une année vous êtes chercheur
chercheur chargé de recherche au laboratoire de géosciences à l'université de rennes 1 1
au cnrs c'est bien ça bien alors avant de partir en amérique
et sur ces contrées que vous avez que vous avez parcouru dans le cadre de votre travail le plus souvent
on va peut-être remonter un tout petit peu en arrière parce que
vous êtes la preuve vivante si l'on est qu'on peut être scientifique oui
chercheurs
brillant promis à une belle carrière et en même temps avoir foi en l'humanité être humaniste
et faire en sorte que les rencontres que vous faites sur
voilà tout au long de votre courte carrière vous avez juste 31 ans quand même c'est pas mal je servirai pas mais
si vous avez des lunettes ouais et du coup ça donne quels sont les liens qu
Une conférence à l'espace des sciences voilà il faut que
L'humain a de l'importance dans votre parcours et on quand on discute un petit peu avec vous on se rend compte que il ya beau
y avait beaucoup de rencontres qui ont
marqué votre jeune carrière et que même peut-être ce sont ces rencontres
qui ont fait que vous êtes ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
si on remonte
votre petit enfin on va dire jeune adolescence vous êtes vous avez 15 ans vous êtes 11 secondes vous n'êtes pas
terriblement bon élève vous savez quoi quelle moyenne pour la vie des
Fêtes moyen de gagner des sous ce soir 34è bases fausses super bass super boss à l'école ça vous intéresse pas
évidemment il est encore pas question de faire carrière dans le monde scientifique
on en est loin vous là seul truc qui m'intéresse c'est les récrés
La faire et puis à cette rencontre
las le prof qui vient vous voir pour devenir prof de chimie ouais
la chimie c'est pas votre truc non plus à cette époque là non pas de règlement c'est ennuyant les courtes et longues
non c'était pas mon
domaine de prédilection
mais ce prof prend du temps un oeil le fait par des moyens peu détournée quand même au départ il dit voilà bon
moyenne super base donc je vous colle c'est vrai que j'étais en retard souvent donc il m'a collé
m'a forcé à faire de chimie maintenant je suis collé la chimie donc
Heureusement qu'ils étaient pas footeux ou
au cou
n'auriez peut-être richissime a peut-être ou pas bah je leur ai je raté oublie
On va laisser de côté
Donc ce prof de chimie vous colle et vous garde le soir après les cours qu'est ce qui se passe
Des examens peu basique sur la chimie élémentaire donc ce qu'on voit comment dire sur les chaînes de télé avec
sami donc et on change de couleur avec des enfants les réactifs
j'ai eu un coup de foudre pour la chimie dont c'était quelque chose pour moi de passer
assez révélateur et de voir tout ce qu'on peut faire avec juste deux ou trois ingrédients ça m'a
donné envie de continuer
donc les études il a cru en vous c'était le seul à l'époque
mais beaucoup et
N'allez pas trop vite parce que c'est quand même assez c'est quand même
ne soyez pas trop modestes parce qu'effectivement vous avez une moyenne extrêmement basses il vous dit
bon voilà il reste quelques mois vous êtes en seconde c'est donc après il faut faire effectivement un choix de filières
la filière s scientifique pour être envisage enfin elle
vous auriez envie qu'elle soit envisageable elle ne l'est pas quand on regarde votre bulletin et l'huile de cette
idylle à la cepap les tables non du tout venant du tout maintenant direction
redoublements
ont la maison et faire autre chose ce qui m'allait très bien aussi même
chimie était quelque chose de moi important que j'ai voulu continuer
J'ai plus travaillé je me suis focalisé sur la chimie et que ça quitte à oublier le reste l'anglais a not good non mais écoutez
Vous empêche pas quand même de faire des parutions
en anglais par la suite et du coup vous remontez votre moyenne vous passez à 17 oui c'était le l'histoire
17 et les buts allaient vraiment très très très bas j'ai promis que je le dirais pas mais vraiment super bas
donc c'est une belle prouesse beaucoup de travail
sans doute aussi du talent et des capacités à
assimiler toutes ces données ces notions en fait pour lesquels vous êtes devenu très friands et très gourmand
propose sur le talent parce que c'est juste le travail quoi quand tu
consommes ce que tu fais tu travailles tu vas forcément le gdra que tu obtiens donc
donc je pense pas que ça soit le
talent qui le
mononcle du travail le travail toujours est il que vous avez votre bac oui j'ai eu mon bac et vous n'avez jamais quitté
Modeste parce que vous n'avez jamais quitté le haut du panier c'est à dire que
vous terminez effectivement 7 cette année de seconde avec 17 de moyenne vous passez en première s évidemment terminale s
et vous êtes toujours majeur de votre propos voilà on apprend que je continue en faculté à rennes
j'ai connu des gens qui vont un peu détournée du prochain mais je suis resté quand même fidèle à mes principes
ça va peut-être faire plaisir à des mères de famille là qui sont scientifiques etc ont des enfants à la maison et kitty c'est
possible on n'y arrivera pas abassi julien gigot
le résultat n'est pas forcément très joli à la fin parce que au moins leur un diplôme en
Vous finissez par vous finissez vous continuez votre parcours un parcours qui vous emmène à pau c'est là que vous peaufiner votre
votre thèse ans c'est sa thèse
j'ai soutenu en 2011
sur la chimie
analytique et environnement c'était une grande thématique
tubes de carbone
carbon conflit avec la particule
donc conflit qui toujours d'ailleurs
en cours on n'a pas trouvé un terrain d'entente mais c'était mon premier le premier challenge
parce que des particules à l'époque l'ultra moderne ultra résistante qui faisait qu'il faisait la une de tous les journaux
ne parlent danger la simulation tout le monde ira l'amiante et
du coup il fallait évaluer un peu le comportement dans l'environnement donc c'était mon premier et premier définir et là on
vous êtes débauché en quelque sorte
on est venu vous chercher c'est toujours extrêmement agréable oui surtout venant apporter des états américains qui sont
assez durs à convaincre l'occasion d'améliorer votre anglais we l'occasion ça va du temps quand même et
C'est l'expérience américaine qui commence pas parlez nous un peu de cette expérience américaine
souhaite tout jeune vous avez quel âge j'avais j'avais des cheveux donc je vais avoir
25 ans 26 ans le plus c'est relativement jeune voilà donc non c'était tout grand tout beau
plein de points de moyens plein d'argent et déjà une prise en compte sur
des problèmes environnementaux contrairement comment dire à la france qui avait déjà un peu de retard ce qui est assez
ironique quand on voit maintenant le président qu'ils ont donc
mais ça reste néanmoins
un pic était avant-gardiste sur les problèmes de nanoparticules dans l'environnement et l'impact que ça tout ça pouvait induire sur
l'environnement et le vivent donc
c'était assez c'était il y avait tout à faire c'était ils ont donné les moyens
donc là on avait
on avait un budget annuel
qui ont été dits chercheurs avaient un budget annuel qui correspondait au budget du cnrs à l'année donc ça fait rêver
on était quelque chose assez monstrueux mais c'était voilà c'était
aussi la porte ouverte à tous les abus mais bien parce que du coup on acheter tout et n'importe quoi
mais mais c'était c'était sa famille de débloquer pas mal de situations de problèmes sur les sur l'environnement sur
sur comment caractériser ces nouvelles espèces
dangereuses ou
donc ce qu'il veut aussi un axe sur le cancer et comment utiliser les nanoparticules pour guérir le cancer
donc c'était super un super intéressant
donc là vous avez vraiment mis la main dans les
nanoparticules si vous ne l'avez jamais vraiment retirer non j'ai essayé mais j'ai pas réussi non
c'était une drogue vous avez quitté l'amérique ou de revenir en france mais vous avez toujours été fidèle à ces nanoparticules
vous vous retrouvez donc à bordeaux oui pour assez peu de temps
oui oui
à cause ou grâce à ma femme voulait revenir à
châteaugiron donc là c'est encore une histoire rencontres humaines alors m amoureuse qui vous
mène à quitter le territoire bordelais pour venir à rennes et c'est une annonce finalement qui vous réjouit
vous me disiez oui par nivard elle reste une ville à taille humaine avec des moyens humains il ya
il ya
de très bons chercheurs à rennes
plus que jamais vu dans l'attitude française donc
on a la chance d'avoir ce ce vivier de chercheurs de support et malgré
des problèmes de combien de finances qu'on peut rencontrer dans toutes les facultés françaises rennes et quand même malgré ses problèmes restent une
pour moi une des meilleures facultés de france donc avec des chercheurs de
très grande qualité et c'est pour moi une chance de pourra travailler avec eux au quotidien là qui est dit fin 2015
c'est encore une rencontre qui va être importante pour vous même si c'est vous qui l'a provoquée
puisque vous allez frapper à la porte du cnrs c'est un peu comme si un peu gonflé mais voilà vous avez des envies
des ambitions plus que des ambitions d'ailleurs des certitudes
deschamps a expérimenté et vous allez frapper à la porte du cnrs et qu'est-ce qui se passe
ben en fait ces
gens vous ouvre en zorro
oui on ouvre la porte et c'est ma femme qui avait l'idée d'aller voir un peu tout ce qui était plastique
quelque chose à creuser là dedans que j'ai demandé au sénat s'il
ya un intérêt à les voir les vaches les plastiques sur les littoraux français
les nobles un anneau plastique sur les littoraux français donc
ils ont été sensibles à ma demande et donc ils m'ont donné
suffisamment on pourra repartir quelques mois étudiés la pollution de la nappe plastique sur les littoraux guadeloupéens
C'était aussi une aventure humaine on n'est parti
qu'à 3
donc dont une gaieté départ en âge de pouvoir manipuler les produits chimiques donc qu'ils étaient la maison mais
toute petite fille voilà c'était c'était une belle aventure donc les crs du coup a
permis à financer cette attitude est et on commence déjà à voir des résultats
qui a acquis
Qui combinent à qui répond à ce qu'on
ce qu'on pensait retrouver sur les plages de guadeloupe longueur
donc pour l'instant c'est tout bon et vous allez vous en parler un petit peu dans d'en cacher puis c'est tout bon
Ce sera l'objet de cette de cette conférence parce qu'effectivement
votre votre truc à vous votre
domaine de compétence et de recherche ce sont les
nanoparticules qui sont issus de la dégradation d'objets fabriqués par l'homme est hélas pendant ces quatre mois vous avez tout le loisir
de constater que
l'homme en use et en abuse ah oui et on abuse après il le fait de manière volontaire je crois que c'est ça le pire
donc parce qu'il y avait des particules qui sont là qui sont bonnes d'autres qui sont moins bonnes et
salah sont pas bonnes donc pour le coup et c'est dommage mais
alors avant de vous entendre on
je vous ai demandé vous avez validé donc ces ouvrages
que je vais vous présenter avant de vous entendre
quelques ouvrages qui ont été sélectionnés par les bibliothécaires de la bibliothèque des champs libres
notamment ce livret de l'association avicenne qui est l'association de veille et d'information civique sur les enjeux des nanosciences et nanotechnologies
il s'intitule nanomatériaux et risques pour la santé et l'environnement
soyons vigilants
qui a édité chez yves michel bien évidemment et comme beaucoup de ses ouvrages d'ailleurs c'est un ouvrage qui est plutôt
inquiet plutôt à charge qui revient donc sur l'origine des nanoparticules
ça se lit plutôt facilement qu'ils n'entrent qui en dressent les propriétés
inédites donc de ces particules qu'on nomme aussi des particules ultrafines et puis enfin il liste il liste les risques liés à leur utilisation
sur
l'environnement sera l'objet de votre conférence et la santé avant de conclure sur les défis à relever un autre
ouvrage qui date de 2014 de roger lenglet qui s'appelle
nano toxiques une enquête qui comme son nom l'indiqué donc est une enquête de cet auteur qui est philosophe et journaliste d'investigation
il est membre de la société
française d'histoire de la médecine
l'ouvragé paru chez actes sud
cette enquête remonte notamment à ce dîner
de décembre 1959 quand richard feynman parle pour la première fois je crois que c'est ça c'est la première fois en fait l'on
n'évoque en tout cas il évoque toutes les le champ des possibles de ces nanoparticules
oui disait qu'il veut du mont amba
on ne sait pas si c'était les parties on sait pas si des particules dont tu parlais où c'était du dessous qui
connaît ou parce qu'il ya la moitié de l'assistance est le premier pour un délire en fait français qui faisait de l'humour
était visionnaire
c'est aujourd'hui votre ce qui vous donne du travail à ce dîner de
voilà donc ça c'est une enquête de roger lenglet et puis si vous êtes
plus audiovisuel que papier si la lecture c'est pas votre truc ça c'est un très chouette coffret que vous que vous connaissez
on pourrait dire approuvé par
julien gigot
et mon stick est mais ouais c'est un coffret de 4 dvd qui est signée de deux auteurs réalisateurs chalon antoine de rouvre et jérôme
chemla qui s'appelle bienvenue dans le nanomonde alors il ya quatre films de 52 minutes est vraiment alors il
Dirige survol non justement ils fouillent vraiment tout ce qui touche
aux nanoparticules dans le monde entier oui c'est très complet ils fouillent
Way est là et le
l'intérêt aussi de ce film qui est vraiment facile d'accès je pense notamment aux plus jeunes
ou plus jeune public je sais pas s'il y en a ce soir ou à vos enfants encore une fois c'est que c'est ce qu'on
appelle un documentaire incarnez donc l'un des coauteurs un charles antoine en l'occurrence va sur le terrain en quête
s'adresse à la caméra il ya voilà une belle mise en scène donc
à découvrir encore une fois au troisième étage à la bibliothèque sciences et techniques des champs libres 1 etes-vous prêts julian
mais je vous laisse je vous laisse la parole pour cette soirée
autour des
nanoparticules dans l'environnement et puis comme chaque mardi soir on se retrouvera à l'issue de cette conférence pour un ton des changes
entre vous et notre conférencier passé un très bon moment à tout à l'heure
Bon à mon tour
donc
avant toute chose je vais commencer par préciser que je suis pas contre une nanoparticule
suis pas pour une particule moi mon rôle c'est juste de faire un état de l'art de vous expliquer ce que c'est une année particulière
en quoi peut être bonne pour vous en quoi ça peut
soulever des questions
par rapport à l'environnement la santé
publique donc
après je ne préconise rien je ne conseille rien j'ai fait juste un état de ce qui est
deux on en est aujourd'hui en
le 2 mai 2017
Voilà donc tout d'abord bienvenue dans le monde merveilleux d'une révolution d'une révolution pardon redoutablement
invisible donc en effet une particule par défi nation on peut pas la voir à moins que vous soyez superman
personnellement moi j'ai passé cinq ans à essayer de trouver
j'arrive toujours pas à aller
à les trouver
donc ce que c'est une nanoparticule dont une définition du nano particules
Aujourd'hui il ya eu des définitions qui ont été
proposés il ya plus de huit ans par des comités d'experts qui sont eux mêmes experts en au comité eux mêmes experts du comité
ils ont défini nanoparticules comme une entité
physique qui a une dimension
comprise
entre 1 et 100 nanomètres
un récent avec au moins une des dimensions
compris entre 1 et 100 donc
cela signifique imaginons vous avez un tube qui fait un kilomètre de long et 1 e le mètre de diamètre
cela reste une nanoparticule
Donc cette stature à imaginer mais
M'a dit ma définition à moi et
une annonce une particule et nanométrique desquels un comportement
nanoparticules ça va pas vous aider et vous allez voir qu'à la fin de mon exposé de les comprendre pourquoi je dis ça
Donc dans une échelle de taille donc vous avez d'abord les
vous avez des bactéries qui font à peu près mille nanomètres
vous avez les atomes qui sont autour du 01 au maître et entre les deux donc vous avez toute une gamme qu'on appelle la gamme
colloïdal
qui fait entre un et 1000 da le mètre et dans laquelle on peut y incorporer les nanoparticules qui font
entre 1 et 100 dans au moins une de leur dimension
Depuis
cinquante monde s'alarme ressources et nanoparticules
c'est nouveau c'est dangereux
mais en fait ces nanoparticules sont présentes depuis la création de la terre on existe des nanoparticules naturelles qui sont qu'on
respire chaque jour qu'on on vit avec nous mais nous sommes un assemblage de nano particules carbonées
Et dans les vins de particules naturel on peut identifier donc
j'en ai liste et quelques-unes dont vous avez les poussières donc il fut des volcans les aérosols marin
l'érosion éolienne les feux de forêt
la combustion de matières organiques
le pollen et j'en pense
ensuite c'est là où ça devient compliqué il ya les nanoparticules anthropique non voulue ou non
intentionnelle donc ça ce sont tous des particules qu'on produit sans le vouloir
vous avez tout ce qui sort du pot d'échappement et
surtout les anneaux plastique donc je vous expliquerai enfin non exposés qui correspond à un de mes champs de recherche
principal et enfin celle là ou que tout le monde panique depuis quelques années et d'un aux particules
anthropique est intentionnel donc ceux qui sont produites par l'homme pour une application bien précises
spécifique
guérir le cancer
Produire un nouveau matériau ultra résistant aller sur la lune aller sur mars salle et son soleil aller où vous voulez
Produire des nouveaux champs point les nouveaux cosmétiques
et j'en passe
ces nanoparticules donc sur ce qu'on appelle des nanoparticules manufacturées
et son c'est donc le fief ses longues c'est le mot clé des nano technologies
Donc avec ces nanotechnologies
On incite à ce qu'on appelle une nouvelle révolution technologique donc les dernières révolutions tout arrêter le nucléaire
ça a été charbon pétrole et les nanoparticules sont la nouvelle donc révolution
donc on évalue les investissements à 10 puissance 9
donc ça fait
Un milliard d'euros d'investissements
chaque année donc la production mondiale c'est super a dit puis 105 tonnes les applications électroniques
santé aviation et j'en passe la question qu'il faut se poser c'est est-ce que
Ces nanotechnologies peuvent changer votre futur pour le bon ou pour le moins bon
je n'ai pas la réponse je pense que partant de là pour l'instant
faute et demander monsieur macron même le pen s'ils ont un avis là dessus
je ne suis pas sûr
Pourquoi une nanoparticule est formidable ça c'est bon j'arrête quand tout ce qui est petit
l'être humain considère comme comme inutile faible
vient de particules celle inverse
en fait imaginer un gramme de matériel encore si vous avez un gramme de matériel
compris dans une bille qui fait 1 mm on veut utiliser l'api de votre enfant à mm d'accord
6 7 bis se fragmente en particules nanométriques
Vous du coup vous exploser sa surface spécifique
tous les atomes sont répartis à surface de d'une sphère donc
soundsphere d'un millimètre vous avez accès qu'à la surface de la particule quand vous
désagréger quand vous tombez dans l'échelle nano particules le rapport de surface par rapport au volume
augmente
par des chiffres par exemple une bille qui fait un millimètre qui fait 3 14 millimètres carrés de surface si vous passez en nanoparticules
pour la même masse de matériaux d'accord
la surface est de 314 milles
pour mieux éclairer donc la taille naine des particules plus cette grande surface
Voilà
ça fait des supers chose
s'appelle l'échelle nano c'est l'effet nano c'est à dire grande surface spécifique petite taille
grande réactivité
Il existe beaucoup beaucoup de
types de nanoparticules
il y en a plusieurs sortes d organique des inorganiques
des principales on sait le titanium biopile que tout le monde connaît ça fait la une des journaux le monde
y en a partout dans les aliments voilà
l'argent
donc qui permet de rendre les jambes bleus vous allez voir je rigole pas en plus
la nanon comme la nano quand capitulation qui permet de deux coups de
comment dire de le transporter des médicaments dans le corps humain et
D'autres applications
moi j'ai une petite préférence pour le carbone il est en verre au milieu tout joli
et d'autres j'en passe on a différentes sortes donc de différents composition
Le graphique et pas de traire pas très lisible mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est juste la couleur verte d'accord
Tout le monde pense que les nanoparticules viennent de l'étranger la couleur verte correspond à ce qui est produit en europe
donc tout est dans tout les différents types de nanoparticules
d'accord donc vous pouvez voir que la majorité des no particules sont produites
en europe
d'accord pour les applications
diverses et variées donc le titanium dioxyde qui ne
principal particules
l'argent aussi qui bien qu'ils aient bien bien séparées entre
différents continents
le carbone les
Parts il est bien répartie entre les différents
Continents
donc différentes
particules manufacturés
ont des propriétés extraordinaires qui dit extraordinaire mais pas forcément dire super
extraordinaire des qui sort de l'ordinaire
donc par exemple le dioxyde de titane tio2
c'est un très bon filtre à uv
utilisant des crèmes solaires
il l'utilisé aussi pour les comme
photocatalyseur sur les routes par exemple il permet donc de
dépolluer la surface des routes vous avez une illustration d'une route ou seo
je suis plus est mais en tout cas ça montre bien qu'une route traitées avec le tio2 au sens on a une différence
de
coût de
résultats
et surtout
il est utilisé comme
blanchissant agent blanchissant le dentifrice dans les fraises tagada s'il ya des fans attention les menem ceci donc s'il ya des pannes attention aussi
et là où c'est aussi intéressant c'est que le dioxyde de titane n'a aucune vertu
nutritives qui permet il s'ajuste à blanchir à fixer les colorants sur les
sur les aliments
donc c'est un peu comme si vous voulez une voiture rouge et vous les voulez vous du coup c'est une ferrari en fait c'est pareil
deux chevaux rouge c'est très bien ainsi mais là non les gens veulent lutter u2 dans l'eure dans leurs aliments donc
Dans le ketchup aussi d'autres papiers d'autres emballages alimentaires et
je pas tout citer parce qu'il ya des produits sont
son
son inimité
l'argent
on t'aime pareil comme filtre uv et surtout comment antibactérien dans les textiles les cosmétiques et les
les
les jouets des enfants
Et toute une liste que j'ai présentées qui juste une liste exhaustive il ya rien de
particulier et particules d'or de sélénium et autres articles plus récente qui sont utilisés pour l'habit
l'imagerie médicale
est également comme le 30 ou le traitement anticancer donc pendant mon séjour
aux usa j'ai travaillé sur un une particule de sélénium qui permet de réparer les dégâts les dommages créés
à l'adn humain donc
c'est des choses qui sont maintenant comme ça disait qu'ils coûtent
qui coûte plus que
imaginé et que bien sûr seules les personnes aisées aux us peuvent se procurer
Les
nanotubes de carbone donc d'un atome de carbone dont j'ai
travaillé dessus pendant mater est ce donc qui est plus résistant que le kevlar plus conducteur que de métal
plus fort et fin que le fil d'araignée et même un japonais qui a pensé qui a pensé faire un
ascenseur
de l'espace jusqu'à la terre avec un seul fil de nanotubes de carbone
on n'a pas retrouvé ce champ japonais
on s'est envoyé passer ces personnes sera fait de carbone vont appeler ça serait mon
témoin
les fullerène et fullerène sont intéressants parce que sont utilisés comme crème sont encore des produits anti rides
il permet de capter tout ce qui est
radicaux libres en gros tout ce qu'ils attaquent votre peau qui rentrent
qui fait qu'on vit ici vous avez la peau ridée pas comme moi parce que moi je suis jeune et un allemand
mais plutôt comme vous
c'est grâce aux fullerène les fils rennes sont sont très bons pour ça ils sont utilisés aussi dans les panneaux solaires
Kinder ne marche pas du tout c'est ça c'est ça marche pas des flux rennes
aussi pour nettoyer les routes lévis les routes les vitres voix c'est un produit miracle
est lui aussi
on le retrouve dans l'environnement et ce à plus tard je vous expliquerai pourquoi
alors quel impact
Avant de commencer je vais commencer de présenter ma diapos je commençais par le sud par le par le sud
Excusez-moi par le bas donc des questions aux idées reçues un objet petit
peu
pénétré dans une cellule ça
c'est valoine une rue ou un objet qui pénètre est toxique
tous les objets nanométrique sont donc toxiques
Donc voilà
pourquoi tout le monde s'affole depuis deux ans je sais pas pourquoi c'est celle universel
de particules ces toxiques parce que de coupes peuvent pénétrer les barrières
des cellules
mais l'eau peut être toxique aussi donc si vous si vous buvez des litres d'eau en cinq minutes
en vidéo peut l'être c'est sûr mais vous risquez d'avoir des problèmes de santé
oms c'est pareil le problème des nanoparticules c'est qu'ils peuvent ils peuvent
ils peuvent pénétrer de manière
De mes atouts dernières nouvelles les les parois des cellules des parois des différents composants cellulaires
et
affecter son fonctionnement et ça c'est nouveau
il ya des idiots
dans le monde
Je suis personne il ya une photo d'une personne
qui a utilisé des particules d'argent nanométrique colloïdal comme filtre uv mais voulait bronzer maintenant il est bleu
Voilà ça c'est un cas de contamination
aux particules d'argent s'appelle argyris d'accord donc c'est une utilisation massive de l'argent colloïdal
en traitement ou juste part a pas envie de devenir bleu
ou un fan de schtroumpfs on sait pas trop
réponse doit lui demander
Et l'environnement tout ça parce que là on parle du vivant parle de vous on parle des gens qui vont utiliser directement les produits nanométrique
pour la consommation mais au final tous ces produits
et nous anniversaire tout ce qu'on produit fini dans l'environnement
demandent une manière comme une autre c'est ça c'est l'acte et
Moi je travaille en particulier sur le bassin versant c'est à dire sur tout les
la zone entre le continent les eaux
et le transfert entre les deux
Les déchets à l'heure actuelle il n'ya pas de réglementation sur la gestion des déchets 1 et métriques dans l'environnement
Pourtant
plus vous diminuez en taille plus vous diminuant taille
et puis votre réactivité la diffusion et donc les moyens de protection
doivent être augmentées
cet impact
est même et aujourd'hui donc imaginer mais pas prouvée
en effet il ya très peu de données sur ce comportement et devenir des nanoparticules dans l'environnement
c'est pas parce qu'on tout le monde s'en moque c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas d'outil pour aller les caractériser
Identifié est tracée dans l'environnement
C'est un peu confiance et une aiguille dans une botte de foin c'est la phrase bateau que je mets toutes mes conférences
c'est un pas tout seul
C'est mon travail c'est pourquoi je suis donc payé par nos impôts c'est pour justement cherché donc ces particules dans l'environnement
à l'heure actuelle donc les différents rapports faits par l' ocde les agences gouvernementales les
ont mis en mis en évidence ont
signé là on
signalé aux
commandes
politiciens ou
aux organismes qui décide que les stations d'épuration aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune en france dans le monde qui est équipé et qui peut
ramasser
Et enlever ou extraire concentrer ses seins à particules issues de notre activité
donc tout ce qu'on produit 1 à particules va directement dans l'environnement sans rencontrer aucun acte aucun obstacle
c'est un fait c'est acté et des rapports à dessus c'est référence est donc tout ce qu'on produit en particules va dans l'environnement
alors que pour les autres éléments
inquiétants les plus perturbateurs endocriniens les et polluant il commençait à avoir des choses depuis quelques années on commence à développer des
nouvelles membranes pour poêlé et capté dans les stations d'épuration nano ya rien
le pire c'est que dans les sols on peut enterrer nos particules
sont tellement petit qu'il peut se diffuser dans le sol elle diffuse à travers le sol pour atteindre la nappe phréatique
après 7 et verser dans l'environnement
donc c'est un réel problème
c'est de nombreux de nombreuses personnes on s'y intéresse de bain avant que je sois au cnrs
j'ai des collègues ou au cerege aix marseille ce sont des experts vue
du transport des particules dans le sol et ils ont mobilisé de différentes manières avec différents
types d'exposition tout ce qui est déposé dans le sol finit
directement par une nappe phréatique
On commence à imaginer les doses les comme on en dire les douze les des estimations de
particules pour qu'on pourrait retrouver dans l'est dans les différents écosystèmes naturels
quelques études qui ont montré que par exemple
on peut estimer à 60 10 mg par kg ça vous parle pas mais c'est je fais beaucoup de tio2 dans les boutons d'épuration
à l'heure actuelle on est déjà largement au dessus
ça c'était en 2014
Deux axes qui ont été faits par un organisme indépendant
impôts on osait différencions d'épuration
dans la garonne et
blessures de la gironde et dans la loire ils ont déjà mesuré des toners anteios deux qui sont largement supérieures à cette dose indiqué
dans ses tableaux
Autre exemple les fugues rennes
c'est pas le matériel c'est pas le matériel nanométrique le plus utilisé c'est pas celui qui est
en tonnage et en investissement le plus le plus
mounir le plus conséquent et pourtant déjà des études c'est en espagne
On observe des quantités non négligeables de s'énerver particules carbonées dans l'environnement
donc ça y est c'est acté on peut on peut en retrouver dans notre environnement proche
votre écosystème
et cela soulève de nombreuses questions quant à l'impact que cela peut avoir sur notre sur notre qualité de vie au quotidien et son terme
on travaille encore une fois c'est d'aller étudier
donc comment ces particules vont se comporter
dans l'environnement à ce que l'on se stocker à ce qu'elles vont se disperser à ce qu'elles vont
s'accumuler est ce qu'on va pouvoir les récupérer
plein de questions aujourd'hui
en 2017 on a zéro connaissances sur leur cycle haut débit on commence à voir des pistes à se dire tiens à ce que
parce qu'on sortie de cet auteur d'épuration à ce qu avec un milieux salés à 15 milieux salés ces particules vont
sédimenter vont ont coulé wasquehal ans plus tôt
se disperser s'associe avec toute particule pour rester stable en milieu aqueux
lorsqu'ils vont plutôt
à ce qu'elles vont plutôt
sont formés en aérosol être
repartir dans l'atmosphère on a enfin on a commencé à voir des pistes des chercheurs je travaille dessus en milieu contrôlé pour avoir des données
Ceci que le problème de deux de ses études c'est qu'on manque d'outils encore on engloutit pour avoir une mesure fiable
de ces particules dans l'environnement
et les principales et principal verrou à 7 à cette étude c'est cet outil c'est ce manque d'outils
de métrologie pour caractériser ces nanoparticules
parce que caractérisé nanoparticules c'est pas simple
mais vraiment pas simple mais vraiment pas simple
c'est montrer ses seins c'est un travail de
longue haleine il faut il ya plein de paramètres à prendre en compte simultanément
par exemple à taille
bien sûr voulait me dire ces nanoparticules c'est c'est
la taille qui va définir un comportement une particule qui fait un noeud m une qui fait 10 et qui fait 50 ont kiffé s'en
vont se comporter différemment
La forme imaginons les fibres de carbone qui ce qu'ils peuvent faire jusqu'à 2 microns de long et un mètre de diamètre
pour se comporter différemment qu'une sphère bien pleine qui ne te faire bien bien compact
l'état d'agglomération à ce que ces particules vont rester tout seul dans l'environnement parce qu'elles vont s'agglomérer avants
avancent elles vont agresser et pas mal de colo vide autour d'un de particules naturel autour d'elle à ce qu'elles vont parce qu'elles vont
transporter d'autres d'autres choses avec elle
la surface donc une surface
chargée positivement vont s'accrocher
aux organise s'accrocher aux parois s'accrocher à tout ce qu'elles vont retrouver
alors qu'une négativement avons plutôt serait poussée entre elles avant assez stable en solutions sur un long trajet
la porosité est-ce que ça va capter des métaux
opposition à ce que c'est plutôt inorganiques du titane du carbone pu faire
tous ces paramètres sont à pour évaluer son comportement dans l'environnement son impact il faut prendre en compte tous les paramètres en même temps
c'est là où ça devient
c'est pour ça qu'un critique pour un chercheur en chimie analytique c'est de développer les outils développés les méthodes analytiques
pour les caractériser tous ces paramètres
à des concentrations
ultra faible dans l'environnement dans ce qu'on appelle les concentrations de traces voir doutera traces
L'impact des
nanoparticules tout ce qui impacte toxiques donc sur la faune et la flore donc entre 2000 et 2010 les études concerne surtout les effets antibactériens
des particules d'argent de titane et de plus rennes
et
on a donc un manque il y avait un manque de recul on sur ces nanoparticules en manque
d'outils pour la caractériser ce qui fait que pendant plus de dix ans
on se dit bon c'est peut-être peut-être qu'il y aura il y aurait un effet
pour l'instant on peut imaginer on va essayer de réduire un peu les quantités produites on va essayer de proposer des
réglementations mais en vain donc pendant dix ans en attendu d'avoir des méthodes pour pouvoir déterminer leur impact
est depuis 2010 on a quelques pistes donc on a
les études ont montré que
les particules de
particules de carbone de carbone de
youtube ou les furets ne pouvait induire des dommages à l'adn
comme le titane d'autres particules
comme l'argent vont affecter les mitochondries
qui sont les poumons de nos cellules
d'autres particules vont affecter directement les membranes lé rendre plus sensible aux autres polluants
Ou d'autres d'autre effet que mes amis biologique biologiste pardon pourront vous expliquer
Métaux mois
Ce qui est dangereux dans ces nanoparticules c'est surtout même celui
la personne qui va qui va faire hyper attention qui va jamais en maître sur lui qui va toujours regarder la liste des produits
la liste des composants des produits qui va consommer
C'est un à particules vont dans l'environnement se retrouvent et
bio cumulée et bien amplifier dans la chaîne trophique le plancton va les assimiler le mangeur de plancton va les
assimile le plancton qui a simulé les particules le mangeur de plancton du plancton
et les mangeurs le mangeur de mangeurs du plancton et à la fin qui c'est qui mange
seul homme
ait un effet bioaccumulation et bio
amplification c'est l'homme à la fin on retrouve une dose dix mille fois plus importante que celle présente dans l'environnement
les tests ont été faits
par mes amis bordelais
il montre cet effet bioaccumulation et bio amplification des nanos dans la chaîne trophique
même si vous faites gaffe
vous allez morfler
L'universel
à moins de vivre souvent en haut d'une montagne avec un champ où il ya pas de nanos autour
pas de poisson
pas de viande pas des guides
Ont c'est dur de rester en vie mais au moins vous serez pas impactés par les nanoparticules un ca de bonnes nouvelles vous pouvez essayer
Ce que j'appelle le double effet kiss cool des nanoparticules alors ça c'est le problème pour moi le plus important des nano
avant que le nano soit
Dangereuse pour l'homme
il ya d'abord tous ces polluants con qu'on connaît son présent et les perturbateurs endocriniens les polluants organiques
donc le bisphénol a tous les métaux lourds
L'atrazine le glyphosate qui a été généreusement
De nouveau
autorisé en france
bonne nouvelle
très bonne nouvelle pour les
plantes
c'est paul ces polluants sont déjà bio accumulés et bio amplifié dans les dents le vivent donc dans les poissons les oiseaux
l'homme à la fin on retrouve déjà dans nos enfants pour nos enfants aujourd'hui à des doses de polluants
transmitting transmis par la mère aux enfants
Départ monkland par une utilisation massive de ces polluants
le double effet kiss cool vient de ces particules en fait ces particules nanométriques vont pouvoir absorber
plus de 10000 molécules à leur surface
c'est une moyenne par rapport à la taille
ces nanoparticules
vont pouvoir concentrer ces polluants
vont pouvoir lait concentré à la surface ou en leur sein
et senna particules comme à son super forte avant pénétré toutes les barrières de votre corps avec ces polluants
c'est à dire qu'imaginez vous allez être exposés à une dose dix fois plus importante de polluants
à cause des nano que celle dont vous êtes déjà exposé
parce que c'est une vraie particules sont déjà ont une capacité à interagir à capter ces polluants
plus qu'aucun autre matériau que vous pouvez voir
donc les déteste de les tests de déco tox
de tox ont montré que justement ces particules ont une grosse affinité pour les pcb
Polychlorobiphényles une grosse affinité pour les tout ce qui b d e dans tout ce qu'ils utilisaient comme pour retarder le
Retour de flamme donc qui empêche vos canapés de flamber
les métaux lourds aussi donc le pardon de carbone peut capter une dose mais
Immense de mercure et de et de plomb et le cadmium
Est là où c'est marrant par mon rang c'est que dès que ces particules arrivent dans le dans le sens d'une cellule
les mécanismes qui sont utilisés pour détoxifier les cellules
des sorgues ces métaux et libère dans l'organisme
vous avez ce transport de contaminants dans votre corps
avant ces contaminants peuvent être stockées dans les années ce qu'on appelle les années grace de votre corps
maintenant avec un excédent de particules avons traversé tout votre barrière à tous ces polluants qu'elles ont libéré un peu importe où
Vous ai bien peur
C'est c'est eh c'est le moi le côté c'est le côté le plus dangereux de la particule en tant qu en tant que tel
quand on a nos elles ont en effet
poussé plus l'interaction risque est déjà présent dans l'environnement qui va en faire des des
Espèces très dangereuses pour l'environnement et la vivent
Moi c'était vraiment le c'était vraiment le
Une partie sur les ce qu'on appelle les manufactures est donc issu
par l'homme voulue par l'homme
parce que l'homme a toujours raison il a voulu faire ça il l'a fait très bien
maintenant si on le retrouve ce moment on l'a voulu d'accord aussi on a tous guéri c'est super on le voulait
maintenant je veux parler d'un autre problème
donc qui concerne la pollution de plastique des océans vous à venir il fait un virage à 180 degrés
mais là je vais vous parler des nanoparticules qui sont anthropique il ce nom voulu donc non intentionnelle
là c'est le côté le plus sympa de mon exposé que vous allez voir des bateaux de l'eau donc c'est
vous allez voyager un petit peu
Donc aujourd'hui tout le monde sait qu il y a plusieurs gires plusieurs poubelles océanique dans lequel se concentrent les débris plastiques
d'accord on a des estimations ont montré qu'ils avaient plus de
deux millions de kilomètres carrés de débris plastiques
sous la surface des océans
soit celle qui voit deux fois l'australie
environ une fois australie c'est plus on y prenait puis là on est plein et ça lui prête un mais ça fait beaucoup de plastique
Donc ces plastiques
je retrouve partout en mer nous avait dans les baies
l'estuaire sur les plages pour que tout le monde quand il va sur les plages bretonnes ou hollandaises ou
où les plages
du nord
c'est dans les pages du nord mais ceux qui y vont par en temps
si vous cherchez bien vous trouverez des plastiques moi j'ai jamais été
très fort et ambitieux de ces mieux mais ça empêche que vous si vous y allez l'hiver vous retrouvez les plages sont recouvertes de plastique
Les voies d'entrée et déchets plastiques sont majoritairement les estuaires c'est le plus gros
C'est le plus gros apport de plastique dans l'océan
80% depuis la terre
les rivières les eaux usées et 20% de rejet en mer donc
C'est vrai quand même considérable mais c'est
relativement peu par rapport à ce que nous on apporte au quotidien
Souffle une estimation en l'espace de
deux cents ans
on estime donc là la production mondiale de plastique qui augmente de 6 ans 20%
c'est un marché considérable
l'apport de plastique n'est pas près de s'arrêter donc tous les ans les chiffres augmentent
en 2014 311 millions de tonnes
De plastique
Ont été produits soient vus pour cent du pétrole produite en totale d'accord un petit aparté l'homme
l'être humain constamment l'homme
consomme en pétrole en 8 secondes puisque la terre produit en un an
c'est pour vous donner en quoi pourquoi les ressources s'épuisent c'est pas c'est pas un mythe c'est serré elle est dense et 8 secondes
vous avez une partie qui utilisait pour le plastique
et je prends que cette partie n'est pas forcément utile surtout que la plupart de ces
10% finissent dans la mer
donc 5% finiront en mer en 15 tonnes par an
Et si on fait un bilan de masse
donc on a hâte qu'on a travaillé avec un chercheur qui s'appelle 26 bill donc qui a publié cette étude en 2015 ou
si on fait un bilan de masse donc au moins de 1% des micro plastiques
qui sont observables sont retrouvés à la surface avec cette élite avec les ramassages des bateaux on arrive estimé à
1% des micro plastiques donc sur le tout ce qui a entre ont en tout cas un pour cent
ont le réflexe
si on a un minimum de sens ont diminué son passé où les autres
et en fait on est parti d'une hypothèse que ces particules et est fragmentée en nanoparticules
c'était à la base un délire entre deux chercheurs cnrs qui s'ennuyait typiquement
Et on est donc on a donc défini une stratégie on a décidé d'identifier une zone d'accumulation
pour notre cas c'est l'atlantique nord atlantique nord à droite north atlantic pour les bilingues
On a mis à bas tous à l'eau pas le mien ce que je n'ai pas mais celui d'un navigateur
extrêmement connu monsieur patrick deixonne
j'étais un peu de pub
pas ce qu'est la caméra
ensuite on a collecté tout ce qui est chantillon avec défilé manta avec dédé des trappes à particules on a
capté tout ce qu'on pouvait voir à l'oeil nu
et on a three
voilà on s'est intéressé à tous qui micro plastiques pour voir déjà ce qu'on peut retrouver
Là le bateau
avec une mer calme fait rare
le filet mental qui est utilisée bondoukou pour prélever
les plastiques et non pas les ré
C'est bien moindres est enfin donc livré à manger et sera mangé pendant un mois mais ils sont là c'est du plastique
on voit ce qu'on récupère le petit débris qui font entre 1 et 5 mm majoritairement
constituée en polyéthylène
donc quand on date c'est parce qu'ils ont plus de 40 ans
tous comptent août contre qui des bears au quotidien sont encore un temps de se dégrader dans les estuaires
et vont arriver des sicav en tant qu'homme c'est une production de 600 20%
je vous laisse imaginer ce qu'on va retrouver dans 50 ans dans les gir océanique
Et voilà un peu comment dire une
cartographie ce qu'on retrouve dans l'environnement
dans l'océan donc
environ on a estimé à 200 mille pièces par kilomètre carré
ce qui est assez
assez important pour une zone qui est considéré comme désertique
on a pris ces fragments on se dit à ce que ces fragments peuvent libérer des nanoparticules
donc on a
développé ce qu'on appelle un réacteur solaire donc on a mis une numérisés
réalité solaire c'est pour faire un peu sérieux cnrs on a juste mis une ligne arrivé on a mis
une comédienne solution avec un
plastique prélever avec une solution d'eau de mer on a suivi on a suivi leur largage des nanoparticules
en fonction du temps pour cela on a développé un outil
Spécifique qui consiste à comment dire à envoyer un laser à
illuminer
une petite vidéo pour vous plaire star wars
Rue89 on envoie un laser dans la solution
Tous les petits sentiment que vous voyez apparaître correspond à une année particules
donc au bout de 24 heures les débris relate plus de 10 puissance 15
nanoparticules
donc là on a montré que la lumière uv pouvait libérer des nanoparticules
dans un système qui représente un peu à ce qu'on peut retrouver dans l'environnement hier en termes d'irrigation solaire
en termes de composition physico chimique du milieu
ces études donc ont permis d identifier différentes populations
Donc on a trouvé toujours la partie micrométrique qui est supérieur à milano mettre une cagoule d'un graphique de la taille en fonction du signal
c'est ce que j'obtiens avec mon instrument donc entre 100 et 300 nanomètres on a trouvé une belle population
En bleu c'est le témoin toujours vérifier comme quand ce qu'on fait c'est pas non plus
des choses erronées
on est comme sérieux en effet et en rouge c'est le signal qu'on a obtenus pour nous
pour no ono plastic dégradés
dont fort de ces résultats on a dit bon on repart en bateau nous attend à prélever directement l'eau
dans le jir et on va essayer de voir si on retrouve donc les éditions 2015
toujours le même bateau avec les abandons de marée à bronzer
le blizzard en photo mais ils ont rambo c'est un jour assurent
ils ont échantillonnés plus de
100 points en un mois on sait ce qui est assez considérable
ils vont prélever plus de 3 litres d'eau par points
donc ils ont
stocké ça sur leurs bateaux ils ont littéralement dormi avec des bouteilles ça c'est le prélèvement
c'est moi je suis super relais parce que j'étais quelque chose à faire mais je
serais bien allé
Donc bon prélèvements plein de signaux plastique
Une mission sans
problème majeur ce qui est assez rare
on a pris cette eau on l'a extraite on l'a concentré
de 8 litres par prendre présentement allait passer à 10 mg l en 10 minutes
et dessus on a mis notre batterie de tests d'outils analytiques pour la caractériser ces nanoparticules
Dont la microscopie électronique qu'est ce que tout le monde connaît dans notre domaine
et va à quoi ressemble une eau de mer purifier
Et nous concentrer une bonne mère concentré dans le bain de gier
vous observez toutes ces petites particules
nanométriques de plastique
elles sont toutes cette plus ou moins cette forme un peu des toiles éclater
les couples la composition a été fait de suivre on est sûr à 100% que c'est du plastique donc majoritairement du polyéthylène et du polystyrène
Et les constructions sont de l'ordre de 10 puissance 6 particules par par mètre carré
donc c'est pas grand sens pas beaucoup mais si vous faites
une carte assez grande du gier c'est relativement énorme par rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver dans un sol dans une eau de rivière
Si on fait un calcul simple si on fait le calcul qu'il ya 7 millions de kilomètres carrés de déchets plastiques micrométrique et millimétriques
dans les océans
et si on suppose que tous ces débris micrométrique se transforme
en débris
llano métriques on passe de 7,7 millions de kilomètres carrés à 170 millions ou kim khai
Comme et océans font en tout et pour tout sept cent mille kilomètres carrés
ça veut dire que si on sait que tous ces débris dans le plastique représente plus de
1 7e plus de
20% de la surface des océans
on a du coup les battles bateau repart
chopard
l'an prochain faire le jir atlantique sud pour essayer de voir si on retrouve les mêmes concentration les mêmes
signaux de plastique il est parti dans la garonne deal en juin dernier
il est parti en méditerranée il ya deux ou trois semaines
La méditerranée qui est quand même 100 fois plus pollué que le l'océan atlantique ce qui est normal au vu de son de sa morphologie
et plus en mission sont programmées dans tous les espaces plus ou moins
susceptibles d'être contaminés par les plastiques en soit la surface du globe les otites tara qui est parti dans le pacifique
de bateau le bateau 100 % électrique est parti aussi
est parti de lorient et pour aller je pense pareil atlantique nord et pour le tour de france me semble au tour de france
c est rapide le tour du monde
pour évaluer justement cette pollution plastique dans tous les océans
Et les premières études d'impact des micro plastiques sur le vivant sont assez à terme east
On a les effets
peu importe la quantité de plastique retrouvé on a des effets sur les espèces
à travers sa membrane
il invoque la chaîne trophique
déteste les oursins
ont montré des problèmes lors du développement embryonnaire
et surtout si on imagine que cette échelle micro d'hélène nano
on peut imaginer des impacts encore plus important
on est en train de publier un article avec une collègue de bordeaux ou nantes justement que à des doses
qu'on appelle ultra trace à 10 microgrammes par litre on observe des changements génétiques des populations
impactées par un plastique
donc à des doses ultra faible on occupe déjà un comportement et modification
de la génétique des espèces
Ce sera assez ce résultat
c'est assez effrayant mais d'autres études sont encore en cours pour les vérifier on travaille sur différents types de plastiques pour les sirènes
polypro polytilène sachant que tout ce qui était baissé tous les plastiques on appelle lourd il reste majoritairement les estuaires
eux sont sous étude ils vont impacter directement la faune et la flore locales qui sont directement en contact avec
l'homme
alors que vous me direz les politiser le polytilène qui va impacter les océans et là bas on est on est pas impacter problème c'est
que c'est un cycle ce qu'on retrouve ce qu'on retrouve dans les gir a été dégradée
tout au long de son parcours de l'estuaire jusqu'au juin
On a d'autres tubes qui vont en train avec le cnes aussi de centres nationaux spatiale qui va essayer de cartographie
avec des marqueurs spécifiques
la pollution de plastique à la surface des océans donc ça c'est encore en cours
mais les premiers premières cartes montrent bien des effets on ne l'a que si on
zoom sur une échelle nano on a bien une répartition globale de nos polluants sur l'ensemble des
mystères nord entre pour le jir atlantique nord
donc ça soulève des questions aussi sur le sur l'impact final
Pour conclure je sais pas si niveau temps je suis un
beau conclure je confie pas je laisse une citation d'albert einstein que j'apprécie
que je voulais je vous laisserai méditer là dessus pour
conclure cette conférence
merci
Voilà prenez le temps quand même de vous désaltérer julien
C'est toujours un exercice de tenir
comme ça une conférence
bon merci en tout cas pour la qualité de de cette intervention
beaucoup d'informations alors c'est pas la thématique la plus fun
vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs dès le départ c'est votre travail vous n'êtes pas là pour effectivement porter un jugement à
dire si c'est bon ou c'est pas bon en tout cas effectivement les uns aux particules aujourd'hui font partie de notre environnement
et font l'objet de votre travail merci en tout cas de nous avoir partagé vos travaux de recherche horn
ceci étant ce sera toujours intéressant d'en discuter avec vous vous êtes d'accord oui jusque là tout va bien
ainsi vous avez des questions des envies
de deux remarques à nous partager
Marion et olivier sont là pour vous donner un micro pour qu'on puisse vous entendre ça va être beaucoup plus simple à olivier là il
ya un monsieur avec un pull noir au milieu et qui lève la main ou peut-être vous vous y allez voilà allez c'est parti
le temps que les micros vous arrive et on vous écoute bonsoir
merci bonsoir
deux petites questions la première j'espère que je pourrai être sujets concernant justement je sais pas si vous êtes au courant par rapport aux arènes
certes c'est la nouvelle lubie
technico commercial de l'entreprise monsanto et qui souhaitent les les utiliser de façon massive justement au niveau des insectes
une nouvelle génération a ses petits side est ma deuxième question
concernant de monsieur qu'est ce qu'il est devenu en fait au niveau de son état de santé
alors bien cancer de la peau
pour le deuxième je crois que gaga mais elle l'a chopé
Mais il a pas l'air de gargamel d'ailleurs pas
du propriétaire de guérir mais le sait le chat
oui c'est ça le sait le chat le chat alors suffi comment s'appelait sont pas suivies de l'histoire mais
il se trouve ça plus loin mais pour la première ça que monsanto
Possède plus ou moins tous les
toutes les commandites ou les principal producteur de nanoparticules
pour ce cas je ne suis pas penché dessus je skie les chercheurs de rouen qui sont sur le sujet
Ils n'ont pas d'ailleurs ils ont conclu des choses c'est en cours de publication ou
alors c'est ça peut publier pour des raisons que je quelques juniors mais je sais que par exemple tout ce qui était lié aux 2
et
1 à
particules qui de liposomes dans lequel ils ont enfermé du glyphosate est en cours d'élaboration à monsanto
du coup il faut ça ne serait plus
tout seul il sera enrobé d'une âme particules
c'est un projet hyper ambitieux de monsanto
je vous laisse imaginer le sait dans la même lignée de ce que vous nous décrire donc après
pour ce contaminant précisé aucune donnée pour l'instant mais peut-être que je vais me
pencher parce qu'être
en bretagne il y a un intérêt pour ce
produit et si c'est le cas
c'est compliqué encore mon travail je pense que partir en vacances ça va vous en donner en même temps
Pour être complet sur la sur la
deuxième
question quand même de monsieur propos de cette algérie ce n'est effectivement c'est pas anodin puisque c'est pérenne c'est à dire que il maintient la
couleur de cet
avis après j'en rigole mais il ya des gens qui en souffrent des gens qui est facile voilà il ya
des mines des miniers au japon qui
les gens qui travaillent dans l'argent compte exposer à ses
come on dira cet agent colloïdal de manière massive
C'est pas anodin ça crée des troubles
neurologiques des a laissé d arrêt cardiaque il ya là toute une fille de complications et beaucoup de gens sont morts
Donc ça que c'est
l'argent colloïdal
à l'heure actuelle il ya des chercheurs de bordeaux qui ceux qui s'intéressent
moi-même pendant mon post doc je suis intéressé on en trouve des quantités non négligeables dans les
stations d'épuration dans les estuaires dans les boues
qui sont recyclés et le plus dingue particules d'argent c'est qu'être et perturbent le fonctionnement des
stations d'épuration auxquels sont antibactériennes du coup vont vont modifier tout fonctionnement de
On a conçu pour pouvoir dépollue les eaux donc après
D'argent peuvent être aussi bénéfique mais aussi de sauver des gens les hôpitaux de me soigner les malades donc
On me dise que ce soit cadré on va dans les hôpitaux jeu bien non mais c'est dans les jouets des enfants fait pas l'intérêt
donc
Dit que l'argent n'a pas d'odeur mais il a une couleur alors bien une couleur il est bleu
bon on a aussi appris ça ce soir
merci à julien une autre une autre question
à plein pas une question ici monsieur au quatrième rang olivier voilà levé la main pour qu'olivier vous
vous vois bien et vous fasse passer le micro voilà
Oui merci d'abord et de questions la première on voit bien que les enjeux
dépassent
le cadre du chercheur et nous en tant que citoyens nous sommes concernés mais
c'est qui me préoccupe c'est pas seulement c'est un jeu là mais si c'est aussi la chaîne c'est à dire qu'
il ne suffit pas par exemple qu'en france on est en politique de contrôle des nanoparticules parce que tout le monde d'aujourd'hui et c'est
alors ma classe ma première question et
et quelles sont les possibilités est ce que vous avez déjà un groupe d'experts type diec
sur ces domaines là qu'ils puissent aborder le problème de manière globale et
donner des recommandations par exemple au gouvernement comment fait aujourd'hui pour le les émissions de carbone
et qu'ils soient pris en compte par des conférences mondiales etc pour avant d air et sous le problème
la deuxième question
quelles sont vos relations avec les industriels au sens où
les publications parfois elles sont bloquées par des lobbys industriels etc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous en dire quelques mots là-dessus
alors pour la première
Concernant le
les recommandations notamment par rapport aux différents gouvernements lancent s engageant national de sécurité environnement et
santé
c'est une agence front du gouvernement a été mandaté pour pouvoir
a mis en place un système de déclaration toute personne produisant même moi qui utilise des particules doivent le déclarer
c'est sur le
ses déclarations sur la bonne foi du celui qui utilise
moi je suis fonctionnaire ou je le fais
Mais
Lens est n'a même si on a mis en place cette procédure
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas ou peu d'outils pour caractériser les nanoparticules dans les différents systèmes
donc même s'il met en place des réglementations
il ya aucune sanction ou allez juste
dérisoire et de deux des moyens pour identifier cette pollution seraient largage où cette utilisation ne sont pas à l'heure actuelle assez fiable
pour pouvoir identifier l'utilisateur
le producteur et surtout les doses utilisées
il ya eu des groupes d'experts qui ont été montées il ya plusieurs années
ça change parce que du coup les particules notre connaissance sur cet anneau change du coup tout un train de se remettre en place
Je sais qu'à l'échelle européenne il ya des choses qui ont été faites avec reach c'est un programme on doit déclarer toute substance chimique
il ya un axe qui a été dédiée aux nanos
et enfin les américains
avant trump avait mis en place beaucoup beaucoup de financements pour pouvoir justement
étudiés
les répercussions des nanoparticules sur l'environnement où le vivant il y avait un site web
qui était justement sur la liste des produits utilisant des particules ce site web était fermé en novembre 2016
je reste sur du factuel je décris tous les faits donc
il y avait un site web qui répare thurillet tous les produits utilisant les mêmes particules
donc maintenant l'europe à calquer ce modèle pour produire un nouveau document avec une liste des producteurs
des producteurs des utilisateurs l'oréal
vaut pas les citer
mais en plus mais c'est pas une publicité il le montre sur leurs produits qu'ils utilisent
des nanos pour eux c'est un arc de vente donc c'est pas mais il y en a une obligation justement
de cité l'utilisation et la présence des nanoparticules dans les produits à usage
alimentaire notamment ya parlé de cosmétiques il ya une obligation le problème c'est que 2014 c'est ça c'est ça 2014
en fait il ya un effet de mode les gens il ya deux types de des gens ce qu'ils vont adorer les nouvelles technologies qui
vont vouloir en mettre partout et ceux qui vont avoir super peur des ces nano donc si
ils s'y mettent ce produit vont cibler qu'une partie de la population conclut maintenant la politique c'est plutôt de de trouver des noms commerciaux
ou de modifier ses produits pour qu'ils dépassent cette échelle de nano donc le faire sans en omettre est déclarée ils font 101
Il fonce en 2000 font sens plus ou moins 10
donc devant ils diront que c'est 90 devant nous et donc ses 110 devant l'état donc
il ya des trucs qui sont mis en place mais c'est pas encore
cessé il ya des déclarations il déclare les produits mais c'est
le titane tio2 est-ce que commun entre vous savez que ça plaît ça s'appelait eu un certain
écho laurent
que la robe blanche y voit la
cdu nanoparticules de 10 tonnes
si vous gardez rentrez chez vous vous prenez votre catcheur votre sous vos sauces vous regardez ce colorant
vous savez que c'est une particule de 10 tonnes ce qui paraît étonnant effectivement vous l'avez cité tout à l'heure c'est que ce sont des
avait parlé comme d'un colorant de blanchiment
et les produits auxquels vous avez fait référence étaient tous des produits colorés la fraise tagada pour ne pas la citer
la fameuse sauce tomate sucré ou les bonbons avec la cacahuète ils sont pas
connus pour être des bonbons et des produits incolore
n'ont essayé de mettre intégrer ça dans de l'eau salée voir
mais jamais fait on la met dans la bouche déjà on a la langue tout rouge
je t'aime le rouge c'est ce que ça coûte blanc
titane et ça fixe colorants fait ça fixe colorants sur la surface des nanoparticules d'inde et
des fraises tagada dragibus aussi beaucoup fois que dans les mns c'est le produit
manufacturé où ils plus de titane dans le monde
mais quel est l'intérêt du coup vous disiez qu'il avait aucune valeur nutritionnelle n'y a aucun n'y a aucune aucune valeur
à quel est intérêt pour les industriels d'entrer fait à leurs produits c'est une bonne question
je proposais un colorant
il est performant il
utile facile à manipuler il est pas cher parce que du coup c'est des landes badge qui sont produits
Le tio2 étape est un super produit moi j'adore le tio2 outre
jusqu'ici pour tout ce qui est blanchissement ça ne sert strictement à rien aucune valeur
ça n'a aucun apport
dentifrice
moi je m'en moque savoir si comme on dit priscilla blue en rose
parce qu'il a le pouvoir de blanchir le produit mais pas de blanchir vaut dans la pratique
c'est moi en tout cas ce serait plus qu on rechercherait commun comme en plus il a un effet
catalyse
il ya ilahi cap beaucoup de polluants il capte beaucoup de choses donc le contraire il aura un effet
un effet néfaste si vous brosser les dents avec par exemple
donc c'est pas renseignements le bon degré dian mais
il est utilisé pour plein de choses qui sont
hyper efficace mais pas pour ça le colorant 1 7 5
Il ya eu un cas de 1 7 1 et 2 1 7 1 points à
6 71 vous allez trouver deux colorants qui sont pas la même chose donc c'est le 1
1 7 1.0 c'est la vraie d'être dénomination du co laurent
theillaud 2 pour ce soir avant d'aller se coucher quand on se brosse les dents on regarde tout sur la troupe dentifrice
pour voir s'il y en a un peu faut d'abord et après après on fait de beaux rêves
il y avait un deuxième volet dans la question de monsieur qui concernait les relations
avec les industriels
qui sont des industriels qui travaillent beaucoup avec les nanoparticules oui il
ya un grand groupe français
qui s'appelle arkema ils connaissent les têtes de nos filiales de total comme tous les groupes français
Qui produit ce qu'on appelle les
nanotubes de carbone et les flux rennes un des principaux fabricants
ils ont au début d un autre look carbone ils ont donné 3 4 millions l'état pour monter un laboratoire d'étude soit
l'effet toxique
des particules de carbone
heureusement n'ont trouvé aucun effet toxique
ça c'était avant
donc depuis des études ont montré que du coup il ya bien un effet
donc le rapport il est cordiale
Il est méfiant parce que le cnrs n'a pas de les fonctionnaires publics devrait nains les maîtres de conférences et chercheurs
aucun
comment dire
on parle pas de contrainte par rapport à l'industriel et on publie ce qu'on veut publier on n'est pas limité par
part ça ça la chance d'être en france on a une des recherches les plus libres du monde
comme la presse on peut dire ce qu'on veut on peut dire ce qu'on veut on peut on peut relater
nos résultats
j'ai mis en évidence des effets toxiques de l'argent
sans être inquiétés de dow chemical donc
pense que c'est une force
Après pour qu'ils soient qu'ils jouent le jeu quoi je pense aussi
les débuts on a un produit conteste ce qui est toxique
il sera proche de nous on teste on dit maintenant est toxique
ok d'accord on change la formulation on essaie autre chose ça serait
ça serait la prof idéal
ce n'est pas encore ce n'est pas encore le cas mais au revoir on va attendre les prochaines années comment ça se passait
Alors peut-être d'autres questions monsieur
voilà il ya un micro qui arrivent vers vous
Oui vous avez parlé de
perturbateurs endocriniens mais les nanoparticules et en mille fois plus petit par définition environ quoi
est-ce que l'effet des nanoparticules est encore plus délétère vis-à-vis de nos cellules de notre
de novembre monde membrane caporal extérieur qui passe à travers ne
la peau pour les
cosmétiques etc ou par la respiration par
les différents pôles oim qui peuvent se dégager de ses produits dacquois
l'effet est encore plus que toxiques peut-être will I lady reading vingt dix mille fois plus important que
que les polluants lui-même et il me concentre il compte entre la surface et dans le front ceint les polluants les métaux
et comment s'en protéger
Si vous aviez la réponse sont protégés
En bretagne tous qui comme solaire en scène c'est bon et on est tranquille
C'est juste un
jeu vous savez comme moi que du coup en bretagne c'est là que les uv sont aussi parfois les
plus forts voilà qu'il faut quand même effectivement si on va essayer si on me la crème solaire une fois par an
que ça reste que rien mais rien que ça on montre que les polluants dits fils dans la peau
il traverse en l'espace de 12 à 13 heures les premières sur le premier épaisseur de l'épiderme
et se retrouve dans le sens où j'ai un projet à l'heure actuelle qui consiste à étudier la présence de titane dans le lait
maternel
les femmes
recevaient on a retrouvé déjà on a dosé ce matin et on retrouve déjà dû
tio2 dans du lait donc
non ça laisse à penser que le lait du coup enfin le lait peut accumuler ces particules de titane
et trans mines du coup aux
jeunes nourissons donc
Désolé vous faire peur mais c'est la réalité
Alors monsieur ici et
Madame
Mais cette levée de lever les mains parce qu'en fait on moi je vous vois mais malheureusement olivier larée monsieur et madame aussi de lever
la manche juste avant pourra penser à lui donner un petit micro tout à l'heure merci beaucoup
une chose à savoir ce que vous pensez les plastiques alimentaires
Alors lequel
Plastique en règle générale
1,3 poche dit de conservation pour mettre dans la congélation
qui sont supposés avoir une qualité alimentaire
ce que est ce qu'ils sont en réalité
dangereux quoi pas dangereux pour l'instant on n'a pas de données sur l'impact toxiques ce qui est sûr c'est que si vous mettez un
sac plastique
avec au congélateur au frigo d'un micro-ondes ivre l'arc dès le début des particules plastiques
tous notre test avec un chercheur de pau
un collègue on met des pour pourvoir la cinétique de dégradation des plastiques on met les plastiques dans un micro-ondes
on note que vous avez tous et on libère 10 puissance tous particules à la seconde
ça c'est pas nouveau ça fait très longtemps qu'on nous dit effectivement de placer des aliments à réchauffer dans un four à micro ondes qui
était à 4 bien avant les nano particules et micro ondes
dans des récipients qu'ils soient plutôt en terre ou en faire oui c'est précaution à avoir et
même les films les films que vous avez en fait la nourriture elle peut être vite peuvent dégager des
dégâts zoom ou de l'épée des micro-organismes qu'on ne voit pas à l'oeil nu ce qu'on appelle le biofilm et insu celui-ci à des
attaques les plastiques
et dans cette attaque qui peut libérer des particules de plastique dans les aliments
qu'on n'a pas encore osé mais on a fait des tests sur des
des tests avec des chercheurs de
de clermont ferrand on a ils ont fait des tests sur le
choix de ses emballages de haribo ils ont trouvé des
polyéthylènes dans la surface des bonbons ils ont trouvé des doses de plastique donc
Je pense que oui on en retrouve
en fait le plastiki le plastique d utiliser
le plastique
petit que c'est bien le passé que c'est magique pas pour tous en fête pour l'alimentaire pense qu'il est pas forcément utile
pour l'om pour l'eau on trouve que l'eau les bouteilles en fait de plastique qui quand ils 17-10 et il est fait
il est riche en additif vous avez des nonylphénols vous avez des
polluants des colorants des métaux et ces métaux
Suivant le contenant que vous avez dans vos bouteilles de plastique qui vont ils vont et capté ils vont les ils vont être largué dans
dans l'aliment que vous allez consommer donc au delà du père cité qui dégradent vous avez aussi tout ce qui est addictif
absorbées ou
absorbées
On achète un excellent jus de fruits 100 % fouiller dans une bouteille en verre on pense faire du bien
aussi en vert enfin vers huy envers moi mais en fait on enfin oui d'un certain côté parce que on
on évite du coude
et d'évoquer à propos du plastique
point vaut favoriser effectivement à deux produits équivalents un content qu'il soit en verre plutôt complète après celle qui secoue
la bouteille de bière à côté
40 % plus cher que la bouteille plastique donc on est
le pouvoir d'achat en france et bien sûr il est trés haut comme tout le monde le sait
du coup payer plus cher a encore pour une bouteille et de
verser
mais qui aura une durée de vie moins longues minutes alors de 40 ans en fait on retrouve des déchets plastiques qui l'être 40 ans
le vert sur un cycle plus facilement que le
Il y avait ma dame qui avait une question
Et monsieur ensuite oui marion on lira le monsieur au deuxième rang ensuite avec le polo blanc
Bonsoir
J'avais une question concernant un cosmétique
j'avais entendu parler il ya plus de cinq ans d'un laboratoire à rennes d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils mettaient au point une
crème pour bronzer
qui agissaient faye avait alors je ne sais pas ce que ça c'était à partir de nanoparticules qui pénétrait la cl de la cellule
pour lui faire sécrité de la mélanine est donc activé le bronzage
alors ça me paraît absolument
incroyable et comment peut-on autoriser les fabrications pour
quelque chose d'aussi futile que le bronzage et à quel point ça peut être nocif
je suis d'accord avec vous c'est le problème
tant qu'un temps qu'un produit n'est pas montrée comme toxiques
Il a il est autorisé en france surtout que même si les gens ont fait des études de toxicité ils ont pas
ils ont pas les outils pour mesurer le
l'impact du coup
Ils peuvent être autorisées rapidement pour vendre leur produits après il ya un anneau hinano ceux qui font du nano
masqué et nano
déclaré
des fois le nom fait vendre mais
dans ce cas dès qu'on touche aux cellules c'est jamais bon signe
surtout pour bronzer
mais ces produits n'ont ils pas besoin en fait d'une aide une âme même d'une autorisation de mise sur le marché
stoll sais pas comment ça fonctionne on a on s'est renseigné pour les fullerène
Pour les particules de carbone classique je sais qu'il ya un bureau à paris qui décide de tout ça
Pour tout ce qui n'annonce sa passe d'avoir un comité d'éthique ce comité n'est pas n'est pas composé de scientifiques
Comme assez méconnu en france ce qui nous gouvernent pas forcément experts dans le domaine
ça
c'est d'essayer de mal début on verra demain on verra dimanche l'élection mais mais
ceux qui décident de tout ce qui régule régulation des nanoparticules sont pas forcément des gens qui bossent en anneau
et du coup ils ont du mal à
avoir un peu le l'effet toxique de ce produit
à l'échelle nano parce que pour eux c'est
parce qu'on reste sont là on reste dans un anneau particulier à particules
et peureux salaces une particule ne pratiquent une n'est pas toxique
parce que pour eux dont l'image d'une grosse particules même si on dit nano ça pour eux ça leur est
un anneau est super abstrait quand on y pense les gens ils
ont c'est un mot
ib revendeurs hyper sexy mais c'est déjà ça veut tout dire et n'importe quoi donc
les gens qui sans eau qui c'est de mettre en place des réglementations ça
ça coince parce que du coup les industriels qui a des bons des bons arguments avec
avec un million d'euros d'investis dans des études et kotok se fait avec un chercheur
Pas dans l'est de la france ou ailleurs ou
Montre que ce n'est pas toxique avec une approche scientifique qui est valable
C'est reçu france est reçue favorablement paris quoi donc
là pour le laboratoire la bo de rennes je sais pas où ça en est je connais pas mais
j'irai les voir
ci-dessous toujours deux jours la
station d'épuration
Je pense qu'à d'autres laboratoires on va beaucoup de beaucoup de balles à des fabricants de cosmétiques ce qu'on appelle les autobronzants
le produit auquel vous faites référence et c'est ce principe là en fait d'activer la mélanine sans avoir besoin de soleil
Monsieur alors on vous a déjà entendu on va vous repassez un micro mais on va peut-être entendre la question de monsieur aussi
bas c'est évident que les autobronzants c'est très utile puisque ça permet de devenir président des états unis donc quand même
Voilà donc je me demandais juste combien de temps les
les particules de diesel reste en suspension dans l'air parce que je suis assez surpris de voir que
on peut les sentir
pendant quand même très longtemps dans l'est
dans les parkings souterrains par exemple et je me demanderais aussi donc combien m ou centaines de mètres
elle voyageait une fois qu'ils étaient émises valeur en 18 ans peut-être
sans prendre en compte le vent peut-être
et combien de temps et donc elle se mettait pour ceux déposés il me semble que plus une particule et fine plus émettre de temps
pour ceux déposés
oui exactement une particules fines par enfin ce qu'on ne peut pas particules filles des fêtes de définition il ya
ce qu'on peut mesurer donc
inférieures
à 25 microns il ya un an le nano particules cela il est quasiment à part
s'il n'y a pas de présence
d'autres molécules organiques autres polluants autres systèmes de récupération il peut rester tout le temps en l'air c'est pas un problème le
c'est un problème mais c'est pas il va rester il assez stable dans l'air maintenant les
sociétés autoroutières ou ceux qui font les routes ont développés ont mis en place d un
polymère qui mène dans les routes et les parkings c'est un poulain nano particules carbonées à base de poulet écrit la mid
que des bugs et autres particules cette écharpe les capter directement sur le sol
c'est pas des forces électrostatiques on s'adapte les polluants extraits enfin sorti des pots d'échappement
vous aimiez c'est super
Le poulet green hamid est un des produits les plus toxiques sur le marché en terme de
De captage des polluants en norvège en
injecter des barils entier pour extraire le pétrole justement pour sa capacité à capter les les
particules carbonées et c'est un nouvel
il faut respecter des doses de pau lieu de
démission dans les dans l'air du coup c'est la nouvelle mode on va bombarder
les routes de produits dont tio2 qui aussi la capacité de fixer les particules de carbone issues des
pots d'échappement à la surface ce que le trio de il est bien parce que il est bien parce qu'ils permettent de
les rangs de neutraliser leurs effets toxiques
ils ont en effet ils vont que mounir yvon passive et un peu les gaz
Les gaz nocifs qui peuvent s'associer justement à ceux assez poussée ces particules ultrafines
donc c'est la bonne c'est mon côté des nanoparticules ou titane
mais à côté il ya les autres polluants qu'on a mis pour pouvoir les capter donc
Je passe au japon à votre question mais
donc le diesel sont d'ici 20 ans elle aura plus
d'ici là on sera tous en tout de bras vingt quatre bras et
les jambes mais
Mais moins il n'aura plus je pense j'espère
mais tout sera blanchi grâce aux planches
de ce rapprochement les pots d'échappement un sens si on utilise les autobronzants
oui mais bon en bretagne
Alors
Oui il y aura alors je cherche il ya pas mal de mains qui se lèvent qui a le micro
D'accord au dernier rang il ya une question et puis au premier rang marion l'itie est d'accord et la demoiselle
aussi et encore quelques questions mais le temps passe on a encore quelques minutes puis on va devoir se quitter avec regret mais
toutes les bonnes choses ont une fin vous écoute merci pour fait merci pour cette conférence
par rapport aux plastiques voudrait retrouver dans la mer
beaucoup de ces plastiques en fait font des polymères et vu que c'est du carbone ça peut être éventuellement métaboliser ce que c'est une voie
donc à explorer aujourd'hui où on pense faire autre chose pour dépolluer c'est une très bonne question
à l'heure actuelle il des gens qui s'occupent du
des palois aussi que ce type de voir justement comment ça s'est produit sont assimilés
Métaboliser mais nous pour l'instant on est juste celle de l'ex de détection on essaie de les mesurer de savoir ce que c'est polyéthylène
pour les sirènes polypropylène majoritairement on essaie d'avoir une
savoir ce qui accroché à ses plastiques ont majoritairement des polluants
Des chercheurs essaient de savoir comment ces polluants eux sont transformés dans l'est dans les différentes populations de poissons
ou espèces vivantes qui vont à stimuler ses plastiques nanométrique
mais pour l'instant la dégradation c'est un c'est une question c'est
assez large que peu de gens aujourd'hui
ont les moyens de s'y intéresser
on n'est pas encore à ce stade là mais c'est ce sera je pense un
des principal
challenge scientifique dans les cinq prochaines années un
décor merci
Ici
Pour parler des
Dentifrices entre ces des aliments sous plastique
Peut-on éviter d'avoir donné de la nano un autre logis si vos achète dans les magasins bio
Est-ce que sans jamais ans oui parce que bio
Près maintenant vous allez rire main ils font du nano bio donc
Cti aux deux qui restent ou du délit pause homme qui respecte l'environnement
Je ne sais pas ce que ça va encore je sais que
à partir de maintenant vous protège à des feuilles de deux
emballages papier
déjà ça
l'emballage à base à l'imf 1-2
aluminium tout ce qui est
plus ou moins tout ce qui est non carbonées on va dire voilà je périssables
ouais par exemple donc
après je ne sais pas le sais qu'il ya
des gens qui font des plastiques un bio sourcés
qui se dégrade dans
dans l'environnement
donc je suis forcément convaincu part ça
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait cultiver
des milliers d'hectares d'algues pour pouvoir faire un type de
dentifrice donc
ou alors l'acheter en vrac on va avec son pot en verre
je connais des gens à rennes qui font ça récemment identifié central des photos en vrac à
son endroit cas mais ça marche plutôt bien et ils vivent nus sans plastique
ok
Il vous vient vous donnera les adresses à l'issue de la conférence alors nous magasins en vrac
On va prendre une peut-être une
odeur dernière question avec notamment mademoiselle ici
puis peut-être une toux dernière une toute dernière avec le jeune homme avec la chemise bleue puis après je pense qu'il va falloir que
j'aille faire dormir nos cerveaux nous brosser les dents au teil o2 tout ça tout ça pollue ouais bon ça bon sens et
je pense que les gens qui sont le plus en contact avec les grandes quantités de nanomatériaux sont
surtout ceux qui travaillent avec des produits qui contiennent ces particules ou
éventuellement les chercheurs et j'aimerais savoir vu que l'on connaît pas
les effets à long terme de ces particules quelles sont les réglementations
pour éviter le contact ou l'absorption de ces particules
par ces personnes
vous protégez vous en trouviez c'est un peu le mois
Mais en fait
Les nanoparticules les travailleurs qui on est les plus exposés mais on a aussi les plus avertis
qu on est conscient du risque
concours on met déjà en place des moyens de se protéger
problème du grand public sait qu'il n'a aucune idée de savoir quels produits continue nano donc ils s'exposent de manière plus faible
mais plus risquées à ces nanoparticules
donc nous au laboratoire on ad on a des précautions à des comités de sécurité qui viennent nous voir qui nous remonte les bretelles
voient la meute élégant la blouse travailler sous haute mettez en place des systèmes de récupération des déchets de revalorisation de protection des stagiaires
d'impôts les stages et la séance en bloc mais les chercheurs
sont protégés donc nous on est on est on est assuré de
on a tout un système de protection pour pouvoir
minimiser les risques je dis pas qu'il ya pas de risque
pour l'instant je vais bien
je suis suivi par un docteur j'ai pas de problème de cancer ou autres sur table est non donc ça va
ouais ça reste on m'a dit ça l'est resté
mais logiquement en en france pour ça on est en libre on y perd bon pour ça on a des systèmes de
le système de prévention de sécurité
par rapport aux nanoparticules et entreprises on a remarqué marc ont des systèmes encore plus drastique des
termes qualité à respecter avec des cahiers des charges hyper lourd par rapport à gestion des déchets à la protection des travailleurs
encore une fois c'est je pense qu on est plus exposé mais c'est vraiment vous qui est le plus
menacé un exposé aux mêmes à des quantités plus faibles
parce que vous les bonzes et
une en bretagne
Une dernière question pour le pour le jeune homme alors bonjour
du coup vous disiez qu'il ya beaucoup d'industriels qui développe de nouveaux produits à base de nanoparticules
notamment tout à l'heure avec les tous kelly podium enfin plein de nouvelles technologies
j'aimerais savoir si ces mêmes industriels ils doivent consacrer une partie de leur budget à leur destruction par la suite enfin
à étudier les moyens de par la suite les reconvertir ou les retransformer
non aucun je penserai d'envié pas du tout non comme total son pétrole et des produits est presque identique ce qu'il en devient
Ils ont aucune voie y savent ils essayent d'avoir un respect de l'environnement
maintenant en france on a le thème des
jeux move est donc on a quand même des normes iso tout ça on a des amis en place des systèmes de
contrôle de l'environnement qui sont assez assez lourd respecter dès qu'ils ennemis son marché
Limite on s'intéresse plus à l'environnement qu'aux vivants
Donc ceux qui bonne chose un pas pour vous mais pour l'environnement
mais il n'ya pas encore non ya pas encore 7
euh pas encore cette gestion il n'ya pas encore cette gestion de ce qu'on appelle le cycle de vie du produit on n'a pas encore
assimilé ce
concept des pays nordiques par exemple qui le font à merveille
danois et travaille sur les particules ils peuvent te dire
on va finir ce qu'ils ont mis en place d'un système de récupération des eaux qui sait quelque chose de
considérable mais
en france n'y a pas c'est encore cette politique
faux faux proposé ça au prochain président j'espère qu'ils raillent très sensible à cette thématique
Entre autres rencontres
Merci à vous merci julie un gigot merci d'avoir passé du temps avec nous
Autour des
nanoparticules juste un mot pour vous rappeler que si vous souhaitez
revoir cette conférence m'en parler ou la partager elle sera en ligne donc à partir de demain
sur la chaîne de l'espace des sciences sur youtube et puis rendez vous dès la semaine prochaine
mardi prochain vous retrouverez match centrale sera en compagnie de nicolas gauvrit qui est
mathématicien et psychologues et ils discuteront ensemble de l'art d'avoir tort en toute bonne foi sympa aussi un
faites de beaux rêves bonne nuit à très bientôt merci beaucoup